[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to dirty RT this is season
2 but Jake as last season was all about
dirty RT we decided that we're gonna
kick off this season with guten morgen
guten morgen
he's just an upstanding citizen that's
right I mean I think I think we've had
you know I think it was 12 episodes of
dirty RT being very dirty we're gonna do
well not yet we're gonna do things
different we're gonna become a good
person it's that's what it is it's about
making amends with all the people we've
we've hurt and starting new starting
clean starting fresh getting a new suit
some may call it Redemption first things
first we need to take a bath wait should
we get a haircut first what comes first
Bethan haircut I think haircut first we
can trim it down a little bit yeah oh
that looks nice
all right well let's look it back pomade
oh my god this like is like a whole
different person you're a new man and
now the beard and I love beard it's like
the goatee always looks so sleazy
yeah it does the josiah yeah I mean oh I
think that's good no don't
okay no I mean you could do a little
dipping but you could dip out you can
dip it a little bit
no no no more Myatt no we're gonna take
a bath all right just just for old times
sake okay last time acting like that I
don't I don't like him I'm really liking
that stache the stache is good sure so
what do you do for fun crawl around in
the mud maybe wear a big mask excuse me
good Morgan don't you go start any more
[ __ ] around here
[Music]
you've got a handy I surrender I
surrender I surrender all right all
right let's wipe clean okay okay
[Music]
alright I'm starting clean starting
again guten morgen good morning good
morning okay I'll be good now I swear on
my life sheriff Morgan I would never do
such a thing
stop stop stop I didn't do it
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't say a goddamn thing one more time
I'll make it easy for you I'll make it
easy for you keep the door open
[Laughter]
[Music]
that shop clerk just needs to not say
anything oh yeah okay here we go
don't say it after what you did to me
she kill you herself
I won't have you lingering do your
shopping and move on okay nonsense from
you here's the catalog thank you okay
that's it we're done okay all right I'll
go back to the frickin police department
I'm just tired of seeing that guy all
right weirdos there's no need to shoot
we're good they both just ran their fan
in the hamper
[Music]
Jake I think Valentine has had enough of
your [ __ ] I think we should make our way
to Van Horn Van Horn yeah yeah we've
never been there I hear there's a lot of
angry people up there we need to spread
light or sorry we need a shine light on
that town with a good Morgan that's good
for dirty arty I would not have
hesitated nice around here I'm kind of
new to these parts didn't say anything
[Music]
welcome
excuse me sure you're not my lamp stay
there morning friend always say manners
cost nothing oh yeah good Morgan come on
I'd recommend going blind about now you
wrong upstairs
[Music]
[Laughter]
easy easy
we'll just remember this man let's meet
the rest of this - gillum's Oh baby I
know easy guten morgen my vision goes
red and all I wanna do is I believe if
you can't treat people with respect
what's the point I say ma'am how's it
going with you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
where you from me I'm saved Annie born
and bred use the real city right here
might not look like much but Saint
Francis is the soul not the magic if you
won't hear music like you do you know
I'll surrender I'll surrender
[Music]
that'll be $50 and cheap at the price
you read this and you'll want to give me
a hundred more all right I'll do it
sure the best investment you'll ever
make my friend that's a lot of reading
it's a lot of reading a happiness book
this is one of the happiest books you've
ever read it looks like a lot of drivel
though
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
uh I know I know how to turn this party
around okay so um your lamp you guys see
my lamp
hey I see my lamp sweat exactly issue at
hand what is the matter with you let's
survey the damage fine everything's fine
everything's fine Oh God
don't go out there and that's gonna do
it for season 2 chapter 13 of dirty
Artie so long good Morgan we'll give you
another shot maybe maybe but that's
gonna do it so of course it's that time
in the chapter in the video where we
look at your own dirty Artie's that
you've submitted to us on Twitter I met
Robert and Lurie one word and we'll you
went I met Jacob Dec and we almost
didn't do this but then we saw Aaron's
son of nails submission here and we were
like we have to do this it was it was
pretty funny I like you kind of came at
me and you were like we got to do this
because I didn't then saw this and said
the exact same thing I was like holy God
there's so much to talk about here that
beard it's just beard loads out dude
like it worked there are dirty already
looks sad this is so strong and
aesthetic just like the choice to have
black and white like pair so nicely like
ebony ivory right here look at that look
at that he's got the tail the tail is
perfect
dude that beard though is spilling out
of his jacket like this gun cat matches
everything the ivory handles on the guns
the black gun holster it's so
outstanding I am in love yet this all
over again oh my god he sent in another
one same person this is Aaron son of
Nell who did that one Abe Lincoln are
good you know his his handgun that Abe
Lincoln carried out yeah that's right
most most other presidents had a pen and
he had a gun sign here we've got mild
dish Gambino that one I just thought was
pretty cool yeah that's a that's a
freaking cool ass mask and like so many
masks I see in like this part of the
episodes that I've never seen before
like I don't know it's cool to see
people like fine all these masks I've
never seen son of on do this isn't
really a dirty Artie he just sent us a
picture of our
for Morgan chugging beans during the
killcam I was like well that that's that
that that's the core of 30 Artie right
there that's also I mean I would love to
know whether that was coincidental or
intentional because it's hard to like
predict when a kale cam goes right like
I guess it's generally like when the
last kills but cuz I'd go hours without
seeing one all of a sudden one shouldn't
I go yeah totally he must have been
maybe spam and all those beans it's
awesome and this is Arthur almond right
here this is axe murderer Artie yep yeah
that's terrifying mask he's got alright
it's like some rain just happened and my
God look at those veins I know and
finally Christopher Joe I was getting
shining vibes from this here's already
here it's Artie for sure missiles look
nice - yeah that's not even looks like
Jack Nicholson goes yeah but anyway
that's right God this week please send
us your own dirty Artie's hashtag show
us your arty and we'll include them in
our next chapter chapter 14 Thank You
Jake and thank you guys so much we'll
see you then
[Music]
you